[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
europe où le cheval a tout de suite pas
trop tu es bien pressé nounours mais
jamie m'attendent ce qu'ils vont être
contents hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
pour vous avez des enfants vous allez
être contents car nounours va vous
raconter une jolie histoire
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits c'est quelle histoire
que tu n'auras pas une histoire d'une
petite fille que vous aimez bon coup
devinez
la gauche doit et commence
[Musique]
philippines de la petite fille ondes
gentil qu'aucune charmante et amine
nejmi d'amour
aujourd'hui je vais des mamans à faire
de la cuisine viens avec moi dit elle sa
poupée en la prenant dans ses bras si
j'aime
philippines entra dans la cuisine sa
maman était en train de préparer une pas
veinard philippe il aida à mélanger la
farine à pétrir la pâte à la rouler à la
mettre dans le moule mais compte elle
vit que sa maman garni c'est la tarte
avec des freins
elle se cache à des vers l'avant
du bus du du midi
bientôt le lapin blanc en traçant faire
de bruit et se précipita sur la tarte
aux fraises qui mangent à toute entière
mais quand il voulu ressortir
la porte était fermée à clé
j'ai attrapé la table j'ai attrapé un
attaquant et philippine toute heureuse
criaient sauté dans sa roue jouaient du
tambourin
le lendemain matin
[Musique]
le long de mama temps
oui pas de nouveau but est d'abord de la
suite je n'ai pas oublié j'ai fait
exprès et je vous la raconterai une
autre fois quand vous aurait été sage
vaincu l'indienne les lèvres oui je vous
le donne c'est nous on fait ça toute une
collection allons les enfants
[Musique]
de cours
dbt vide du but détient voici de l'apab
l'emmène au seul mois un patron nous
nous allons en route gro farseth
bonnet des enfants bonne nuit deux au
fond embrasser bien fort vos parents
embrasser qu'un fort vos parents et
faites de beaux rêves revue fait pour
ans
oh
m
[Musique]